all right this is the final meeting of
this course for this semester and as I
said last time I decided that in lieu of
teaching the second semester of the
course in the next term I would give a
sort of a trailer of things that might
or might not actually arise during the
second semester since I won't teach it
until next fall and I usually don't know
until I walk into the room exactly what
I'm doing
or sometimes substantially after that
I'm not sure any of these will arise but
they may give you some flavor of what
interests me about the post 1,500 period
it's much easier to say what doesn't
interest me I have almost no interest in
issues of gender class and race this has
been the great triad of historical
conscience now for a couple of
generations and I'm not sure how much
more there is to say I remember when a
doctoral dissertation that was being
done it was not yet written but the
author had an agent and he was sending
it around to publishers before that the
station was written and it was going to
be the story of what it was like to be
gay in Philadelphia in the 1950s
remember came to the publication
committee of Columbia press and I
thought you know if we publish it cuz we
are very we had a very good list in gay
and lesbian studies one of probably the
first of the university presses said you
know then we'll have a book on what it
was like to be gay in Dayton in the
1950s or in Pensacola in the 19th in how
much how much do you need to write about
any given subject before you have pretty
much
cleared the air in the matter so gender
race and class don't interest me very
much to a even greater degree I have
almost no interest in the concept of
modernity I for the life of me really
don't know what it is and I think
chewing on it any longer is not going to
produce any more flavor it's like an old
piece of gum that at a certain point
it's just chewing and if you don't know
what more darn it is then what in the
world is postmodernity other than taking
that old piece of gum and chewing it on
the other side of your mouth it's so I'm
not interested in the impossible
guarantee this manages to leave me way
out on some other limb in a contemporary
historical disciplinary terms and I'm
happy to be there but it means that I
don't have a great overriding conceptual
theme that I would follow in the second
semester except to try and talk about
the whole world one of the problems I
see with the issues of gender race and
class and with modernity is that you
know you you track down the roots and lo
and behold you get to Europe and I think
that there are other things that I would
rather talk about so I've jotted down
eight or ten topics and I'm just going
to say a little bit about each of them
or as much as I can go through to
suggest some of the things that I think
tend not to be discussed in world
history Zenor in textbooks or in more
one-off one-volume world
things but I think should be the first
of them picks up from a lecture of I
gave earlier on the seeming reversal of
climatic importance as you move from the
Western Hemisphere to the present from
the eastern hemisphere to the Western
Hemisphere so that the tropics that are
understood in the eastern hemisphere to
be places of exoticism lassitude
savagery and human limitations in terms
of anything that could contribute to
civilization that appears to and all the
the stuff that people like to write
about is in the temperate zone
particularly the North temperate zone
and in the Western Hemisphere it's
reversed and all the stuff people like
to talk about is happening in the
tropics nobody ever accused the Aztecs
the Incas of lack of energy or you know
being too warm to build an empire while
the temperate zones were very very
lightly populated by comparison with the
tropics and that circumstance of
tropical vigor versus tropical indolence
and temperate zone indolence versus
temperate zone vigor as you shift from
hemisphere to hemisphere I think is a is
an intriguing subject as I mentioned
before now what I would do if I were
pursuing this the next semester was to
spin out some of the implications of
this and perhaps the
the most striking is that in the
temperate zones to which the Europeans
migrated in the post exploration era
that is to say North America the
southern cone of South America and I'm
going to throw in Australia or the
southern Australia into this even though
it is in the eastern hemisphere it was
not a known continent one of the
striking things I don't think has been
attended to very much is the emptiness
of these areas to encounter empty
territory is very different from moving
into a world that is already fairly
heavily populated now of course they
were not empty but one of the results of
the European expansion into the new
world and into Australia in New Zealand
was the decimation of the local
population so that a population that
have been not that had never been
terribly dense becomes much much less
dense as a result of the diseases that
come with the Europeans so that in these
three areas the Southern Cone North
America and Australia Australia New
Zealand you have enormous amounts of
land that
is a extraordinary phenomenon
particularly from the point of view of
Europeans who are coming from a
continent that had filled up its land by
the 16th century and where frontiers had
closed and the issue of fighting over
who gets what land have become central
to to the politics now you've had a
place with vast quantities of land and
of course when you look at the history
of settlement the the notion of owning
land becomes a a riveting issue for
people who move it isn't that you know
people migrate from Europe to North
America or to Australia in order to do
exactly what they did before you know be
a shoemaker or a cordwainer or whatever
I guess cordwainer some shoemakers the
same thing but rather there's the idea
that you can get land and I think the
that is a an interesting phenomenon but
you also have a an aspect of it because
there were areas of empty land in the
old world let's say the Eurasian steppe
was comparatively empty there were some
comparatively empty areas elsewhere but
what you had in the empty areas of the
old world was pastoral nomadism so that
if you moved into the region step or
into oh some of the lesser populated
parts of the Middle East North Africa
you know arid zone northern India some
areas of temperate zone southern Africa
you moved in to an area that was not
heavily populated but the population was
made up of pastoral nomads
who are exploiting the land in a in an
efficient fashion but not an efficient
fashion from the point of view of a
monetized market economy in other words
having animals on the land constituted
the form of wealth that was valued
rather than having animals that could be
exchanged for money or other goods which
were then regarded as a form of wealth
having Goods was of limited value for
pastoral people's because they had to be
mobile
so that pastoralists needed wealth that
was as as migratory as they themselves
were and the animals constituted that
well but what you had in the in the new
world in Australia was empty land that
did not have pastoral nomads because you
did not have herd animals among the
native fauna so the result is that you
have a vast surge of European animals
into these areas of the southern cone
North America and Australia sheep and
cattle horses donkeys pigs etc there is
a very nice book called a plague of
sheep that talks about the the arrival
of sheep in northern Mexico and the
Texas New Mexico Arizona area and
showing that the Sheep multiplied with
absolutely incredible rapidity
so you started with a few sheep and
seemingly it was just a matter of years
you had millions of sheep and it raised
it raised an interesting question
there had been animals in these
semi-arid and arid areas before like
pronghorn and so on and there had been
animals that ate them
you know wolves and cougars and so on
but they didn't eat the Sheep or they
didn't eat the sheep fast enough I think
that the why that's the case I think it
would be interesting to find out I mean
was it that if you were a cougar you
thought I could eat that but it's just a
big mouthful of wool and and frankly it
doesn't taste that good it's all yeah
whereas here you have a nice lean
pronghorn I'd rather eat it one of the
things about prey predator systems is
that the prey animals evolved in tandem
with the predator animals and they they
expect to be I mean they know what they
expect to eaten by and the predator
animals know what the prey animals are
and I'm not sure the Cougars knew what
the sheep were you know was that
fluffball really edible and would you
prefer it but whatever the case either
because of remarkable efficiency or
reproduction which i think is part of it
or because the Predators did not pray
sufficiently upon the new animals you
had the fairly short period of time
millions of sheep and then you had a
demographic collapse in which almost all
the Sheep died because they had no food
and eaten everything in northern Mexico
and then you had a huge die-off and then
you had a gradual rebuilding and then a
sort of equilibrium of that that comes
about
but this has almost nothing to do with
human intervention other than the
introduction of machine because there
was no value in owning sheep if you were
to pastoral nomads owning an animal only
meant something if you could either use
the product from the sheep or sell it
the problem is that there was no market
so the only things that were sold and
even then primarily for animals that
were in areas close to seaports would be
things like tallow where you would boil
parsley animal down in order to get big
barrels of fat because tallow could be
sold to two shipbuilders or ship
Outfitters because tallow was very
useful onboard a ship but typically the
the animal's carcass was simply left you
know stripped of its you know you could
sell the hide the leather you could sell
the tallow but there was no value to the
meat you just leave thousands of sheep
or cattle lying there skinned in the
countryside for first Cavan jurors to
eat because they didn't have any value
so one of the things that happens is
that these temperate zone areas become
the locus of a new relationship between
market and food production and that is
what I what can we call branching
economies in other words there were no
ranching economies on on that on a
parallel scale in Europe although Spain
approached it with its wool Spain and
England approached it with the sale of
wool but by and large we are dealing
here with ranching economies that are
a a singular aspect of of the temperate
zones of the colonial temperate zones
and that is part of a broader phenomenon
which is FP colonial temperate zones
become huge sources of food for the
world down to the present day this is
where great quantities of a food can be
produced and marketed there is a
relationship of food production to the
market and not just the domestic market
but ultimately to the export market that
that singles out these areas because one
of the things I think that ultimately
has has to be discussed it's why the the
temperate colonial zones in many ways
follow a very different track
politically economically from the
European Metropole now related to that
there is world Systems Theory which is
the brainchild of the SUNY Binghamton
professor Immanuel Wallerstein and in
Wallerstein's theory which is a derived
from from Marxist areas of thinking you
have the notion that there is a world
system in which Europe is the core and
other parts of the world both colonies
but also parts of the world that are not
colonized by the Europeans though they
become part of a periphery feeding goods
into the European market it was the last
generation and still is a very
attractive theory because it shows an
economic relationship that is sort of
undeniable and you
have these goods coming from the
periphery into the core and it also can
be interpreted as as explaining why the
countries and the periphery do not
develop in the same way that the
metropolitan core does in Europe because
the Europeans deliberately take steps to
curtail non agricultural or non
commodity production in these in these
colonial areas and that would be
discussed in almost any world history
textbook the its relationship of Europe
to the colonial core the problem with
the theory and that one that I would be
talking about would be that it only
engages orget engages primarily those
people in the non European periphery who
are who become engaged in the world
system most people don't most Chinese
farmers do not produce for for the
European Metropole the same thing in
most you know in India most most areas
what happens often in world system
theory is that you take out you take
certain industries and certain products
and you develop their story in detail
and you show who does the exploiting of
the product and where do the profits go
and so forth and that's all very very
interesting but you tend to leave out
things that happened at the same time
that we're not either not part of the
system or that were periphery to
periphery relations instead of quarter
periphery relations sometimes you will
get a discussion that will deal with
periphery to periphery in other words
the growing of opium in Iran
and India for sale to to China is a
periphery to periphery relationship and
you you focus on the European companies
that carry out this kind of activity of
backing the production of opium for the
sale in China and so on but there are
other products that go from periphery to
periphery that are left out of this and
knowing why
what products they are and why why they
develop in ways that are outside the
world system an interesting question
with respect to o to world system theory
an example would be pot pot in Somalia
and Yemen is chewed daily it's a mild
feel-good substance their leaves of a
tree basically everybody in the country
spends all afternoon sitting around
chewing cop and feeling pretty pretty
damn good occasionally sending off a
little parcel by FedEx to America but
but otherwise just just feeling pretty
good but pot does not become one of the
great colonial addictions Coffee does
yeah
that's right and and you you know if you
want cots in New York you have to get it
from from an airline stewardess who
flies to Yemen but but it's a plant that
can be grown in other places I mean what
is the great enterprises of the 19th
century in particular is the
transplanting of animals and plants to
new environments so that say hashes
they're native to Brazil but the
Brazilians apparently never liked caches
very much anyway they didn't grow much
so all the cashews end up being growing
up growing over in the Indian Ocean or
vanilla the vanilla bean is native to
central Mexico
you had Europeans who took the vanilla
plant to various places in the old world
tropics particularly in the Indian Ocean
Madagascar and Rhea Union particularly
the French were interested in vanilla
and they grew the plant or plant grew
just fine and they and it never produced
any fruit no beans and that was because
the the plant did not pollinate reason
pollinate was discovered in 1837 by a
French scientist who found that there
was an itty-bitty B in central Mexico
that pollinated vanilla plants but the
being could not be transplanted you can
take could take the the vanilla out of
Mexico but you couldn't take the B out
of Mexico so this was a great problem so
this guy he figures out a way to
pollinate the vanilla plant by hand and
it is so clumsy that it pretty much
flops as a of enterprise and then
there's a grower on the island of
runion in the Indian Ocean who has a 12
year old slave named
Edmund Albus and he has him as sort of a
you know a favorite boy around the house
and follows him everything and you know
fouls him everywhere to his gardens and
so forth and sees what he does and lo
and behold the the owner of the gardens
discovers that his vanilla plants are
producing beans and nobody else's are
and so he asked around and he finds out
that Ed Mon knows how to pollinate
vanilla plants by hand and he invents it
an industry proceeds to arise from the
invention of a twelve-year-old slave on
the island of Valen young and almost all
of the natural vanilla in the world
today is produced in Madagascar
Mauritius
Reunion bees island in the Indian Ocean
because of the discovery of Edmund Albus
and unveil you know there is a small
statue of mr. alveus who died in poverty
in 1880 and is sort of forgotten but you
know the it's assumed that it's the
Europeans who do these things and I
think ed bone obvious is one of the
great the great counter examples of the
Sierra interestingly there was a french
botanist who claimed that he had taught
alveus how to pollinate the plants and
he tried to get credit for it and there
were so many witnesses and so much
testimony that he was revealed to be a
fraud and it was alveus who who did it
18:41 his slaves were freed by the
french in 1848 so he is eventually
afraid
but he made no money but then you you
know so cops could be grown elsewhere
but then you have say your Belmonte you
go to org way or Argentina yerba mate a
is a common beverage but you know it
doesn't it didn't travel in the way the
coffee and tea traveled and yet it'd be
very very important coca tea
we have cocaine which comes along fairly
late but you know if you make a trek up
to Inca territory they'll give you coca
tea to help you deal with the altitude
which is coca leaves in in hot water and
but why isn't coca why doesn't it become
one of these colonial stimulants like
coffee or tea or opium or or chocolate
interestingly you know that there's this
whole business of coca cola and what is
the secret formula of coca-cola
coca-cola apparently contains D cocaine
eyes coca leaves that are the the
psychoactive substance in cocaine in the
coca leaf is extracted and the the deed
the denatured leaves are provided to the
coca-cola company and they become part
of the flavor although the most
distinctive part of the flavor comes
from vanilla and cinnamon but the coca
is there so then you think whoo-hoo
extracts the cocaine from the leaves and
what do they do with the
with the stuff they extract it turns out
that the extraction is done by the
Stepan Corporation in Illinois and they
sell the the active substance to
Mallinckrodt laboratories for scientific
research and provide the leaves there's
a company that processes food you know
herbal substances for various purposes
and it was founded by a man named Alfred
C Stefan jr. Alfred C SAP and the third
is a professor of political science here
at Columbia University I have not been
able to find any absolute proof that he
is the son of the guy who was processing
all the cocaine in the country alum self
likes cigars but you know it's a small
world isn't it but you also get I say
periphery peripherally periphery things
so that for instance if you if you look
at the tea that has grown in Iran and
the Iranians are wicked consumers of tea
that wasn't brought in by the Europeans
that it was a Iranian ambassador to sail
on what is now Sri Lanka who brought in
the idea of having tea plantations along
the Caspian coast so a world Systems
Theory is a wonderful tool but it it
tends to - it opens your expands your
vision in certain ways but can also
limit your vision other ways and that's
something that I would like to talk
about
oh okay post domesticity I think this is
really important even though nobody else
does the I talked about the development
of ranching now the the period of the
last 200 years has seen an extraordinary
and unprecedented evolution in the
relationships between humans and
domestic animals it's seen the emergence
of what I call post domesticity in a
nutshell the very large nut what I'm
talking about here is a long term world
history of animals I've asked you it
early in this course to read a couple of
chapters of my book on this where you
start with humans hanging out with a
whole suite of of wild animals then a
few species become domestic in
complicated ways that we don't fully
understand and humans now are faced with
the world that has two categories of
animals it has domestic animals and has
wild animals and everybody recognizes
that a domestic animal is not simply a
wild animal tamed but rather it is born
domestic and it never becomes wild as it
grows up so the you then have a
extraordinary evolution of relationships
within domesticity and those
relationships move from being at least
in my interpretation for being primarily
symbolic ritual relations in which the
animals play an enormous role in the
imaginary of the populations that have
it so you know things like Egyptians
worshipping a god they see as
represented by
by a cow or by a a donkey or something
like that
initially the use of the animals is
fairly secondary to the imagination to
the imaginary role of the animals but
over time that relationship reverses and
what you get is an increasingly use
oriented attitude toward animals that
reaches its peak in in the thinking of
descartes with the idea that an animal
is simply a machine invented by God that
is because it is a divine invention more
clever than the cuckoo clock but
nevertheless it is as insensitive and as
devoid of a soul and as devoid of
feeling or thought as a cuckoo clock so
this became the philosophical
underpinning for an exploitation of
animals that increasingly in the 18th
and 19th centuries focused upon viewing
animals primarily as products rather
than as sentient beings and this lays
the groundwork for a reversal of this in
the 20th century and the emergence of
what I call post domestic feelings which
are those feelings that people have when
they consider the exploitation of
animals factory farming or wanton
killing or you know cruel
experimentation whatever you want that
views the exploitation of animals has a
deeply immoral activity and as a
consequence or in relationship to it
adopts behaviors that are post domestic
behaviors
so post-tests domesticity which is by no
means universal but is becoming
increasingly widespread involves things
like elective vegetarianism where
without having any religious tradition
that requires that people decide that
they wish to be vegetarian or vegan
either because they feel it is healthier
which is common in many cases or because
they don't like to eat anything with a
face you know human children probably
always had to be you know coaxed into
eating meat but in post domestic homes
often the desire of a child to avoid
eating an animal often ends up ruling
the entire family and so the family
becomes vegetarian in order to please
the seven-year-old so you have elective
vegetarianism you have opposition to
hunting and to animal experimentation
you have a a vastly increased interest
in discovering the continuities between
humans and animals in other words if the
Cartesian approach was to say that you
have an utter disconnect between humans
who have a soul and animals that have no
soul no intelligence no memory no
feeling the effort now is to discover
that in fact humans and animals are all
are all together and they so we have an
interest in whether we can teach
language to primates whether whales and
communicates
in something that we might call language
this is all part of post domesticity and
then another part that I won't go into
but fascinates me is the peculiarity
that I'm not exclusively in post
domestic societies but in post domestic
societies as people become more and more
distant from animals that say most
people today in the United States grow
to adulthood without ever seeing an
animal killed I've taken show of hands
in my classes and will find will maybe
10% have seen an animal killed I take a
show of hands in Lebanon and I got 90%
see have seen animals killed so that the
the notion of killing an animal is a
becomes increasingly something that
produces anxiety and that carries over
into a complex of
things in which the society in which
people do not want to kill animals they
are totally opposed to killing animals
but they really like to watch killing on
the screen so that as the experience
with the actual killing of things
diminishes experience with the imaginary
of killing increases so that horror
movies and now of course everyone's
favorite the zombie headshot
these increase and people relish
imaginary killing as they are revolted
by by real killing
sometimes this carries over into the
real world into the notion of oh those
people don't value human life the way we
value human life in some political
conflict because the once you have
stopped killing animals you can actually
think that it's wrong to kill people and
many people do think it's wrong to kill
people but you know in these post
domestic societies that are of European
background as most of them are they
evolve from a social system in which the
elite for thousands of years
had at least among the males as their
primary adult activity was killing
people this is what the nobility did and
what they were trained to do
and I find it in teaching history one of
the most difficult things is to is to
really think about a battle with like
battle axes you know where you go up to
someone and you bash them in the face
with an axe but then you know you go to
your to your xbox you think hey I can do
that
or you know first-person shooter games I
love first-person shooter games you got
to kill everybody
so this is this has to do with the
separation from animals I could go into
the whole thing as well with sexuality
and the the rise of pornography and so
forth which also corns coincides with
with the disappearance of human
experience with animal sexuality and
childhood
I'm not going to pursue this right now
I've written on this but the point is
that the issue of human relations to
animals which can be traced back 100
even 200 years particularly in Britain
it is an issue that is primarily focused
upon the ranching economies that I've
talked about and upon a Great Britain
and as more slowly than experienced in
the rest of Europe and separates
so-called Western conscience from most
of the rest of the world and one of the
interesting questions to raise for the
future is after the success of the world
campaign against slavery and after the
the hope for success of the world
campaign to to eliminate wanton
discrimination against women and after
the possible success of a world campaign
to diminish discrimination against
people of of varied sexual expression
will there be a world campaign to to
anathematized or criminalize the killing
of animals in other words will
vegetarianism become a moral cause that
gets embodied in international relations
and so forth or not and I think it's
very likely that it then it will
but that is for the future and all I'm
trying to point out is that we have a
very interesting development in the area
of human animal relations not the next
one do you have to be enlightened to be
scientific there was a common place for
travelers from the 16th century onward
when they started to encounter savages
in newly explored parts of the world
newly explored from the European
perspective to see them as cognitively
incapable of certain things that that
Europeans are capable of and gradually
you have the idea that Europeans can do
science because they have gotten rid of
of God and that the the questioning of
the Roman Catholic faith and the failure
of the Protestant faith to produce a
credible alternative and the rise of the
Enlightenment you have the Scientific
Revolution is associated with
secularization and so you had people in
the 19th century who said well Muslims
or Hindus simply can't be modern people
unless they can get rid of their of
their foolish beliefs because that's the
essential thing they don't understand
mechanical things they don't understand
scientific processes then you go a
little bit farther along in time and
travelers to the same area let's say
Afghanistan who used to say that they
cannot understand anything mechanical or
scientific are saying they are so clever
on imitating Western arms that they can
build a gun that's just like a Western
gun because it kind of monkey like they
they can imitate you know
you see monkey do and so on and then
gradually you have the idea that well
maybe they could actually make their own
weapon because what's happened is that
science that was originally thought to
be a European sort of wholly owned
subsidiary of Western culture has become
global and people can be not only
successful scientists but brilliant
scientists without having to ever read a
manual cut without ever having to quit
reading the Quran this you know for
people who have for whom the the great
story about guarantee is the rise of
industrialism and science and secularism
the fact that it can be done by anyone
is let us say off-putting
so now when you talk to people about
this if you raise the issue about why is
it that English is not spoken on several
floors of Columbia buildings that have
natural science departments because
Americans don't do natural science
anymore but we send professors over to
China to to interview people for entry
into our physics department or something
like that why is it that these people
who are not the children of the
Enlightenment why is it that they're
doing the science and the answer is
given is because we have the equipment
we have freedom they can come here and
they are free to be great scientists if
they stay home they will be you know
sent to a reeducation camps or something
like that and now it's it isn't that the
scientific revolution and the mentality
of the Enlightenment has produced these
things but rather it is it is the
freedom that we have plus this really
nifty equipment that makes it possible
this is a losing battle in over time
science is not going to be a Western
thing and we're already finding that so
many of the people who do science in
this country are you know Indians or
Pakistanis or Chinese or Koreans or
anybody about Americans because they're
too busy working on Wall Street to make
money we haven't really come to grips
with what that means in sort of world
historical terms and I think it's one of
the one of the things that will happen
so that it may be that
let's say we tend to look at Nobel
Prizes in terms of the passport or the
birthplace of people and it may be that
you start looking instead at where the
work is carried out one of the most
interesting experiments that currently
going on is organization known as cows
or the King Abdullah University of
Science and Technology this is a
university that has been built in Saudi
Arabia it is endowed sort of a sort of a
Harvard level endowment I mean it has
vast billions of dollars that are
dedicated to it it is physically
isolated from everything in Saudi Arabia
that could be the negative influence and
there are several things in Saudi Arabia
but it could be negative influences and
the determination of King Abdullah the
theory is that if you put enough money
and enough equipment into an enterprise
and you dedicate it to producing
cutting-edge science that you will
within a very brief number of years be
getting Nobel prizes
coming out of Saudi Arabia that's
interesting an interesting proposition
can you force-feed scientific
achievement in this fashion now many
people are openly skeptical of this they
say this is typical of you know Saudi
hubris thinking that they're as smart as
anybody else on the other hand if you
look back at the Bolshevik Revolution
you'll find that exactly the same thing
the Soviets said you know Russians can
produce science big science as well as
anyone else if they have the money in
the start and the dedication of the
government and they did
now one could say that Russians are
Europeans and therefore they have that
little science gene that all Europeans
have but but you know it's if it is not
implausible to think that we will begin
to see major scientific achievements
taking place in Saudi Arabia over the
next decade or two and that's going to
be very difficult I mean the ownership
of science has been so much a part of
the of the story of modernity that to
have it migrated away from Europe will
be very difficult so you're going to
have to come up with a new a new
historical understanding of how this
happened then you can say well is it
just money is it just money is that the
reason Europe became science because
they they they mustered their financial
resources differently say yeah but they
have organizations they have Oxford and
Cambridge for example of course what
they taught there was Greek and Latin
but is it money
is it social networking what is it is
religion something that prevents science
or is it is religion something that is a
matter of indifference from the point of
view of science the whole story of how
important the Enlightenment was may have
to be a reconsider we've always diddled
this story a little bit you realize that
in the history of science technology the
the European tradition has a virtually
said other people invented things but
look what we did with them
we were so much more ingenious you know
the Chinese have the south-pointing
chariot which was the seed of the
compass but we're the ones who really
developed the compass or the Chinese had
fireworks but we learned how to kill
people at a greater efficiency than the
Chinese or so forth and so on so that so
for a long time the Europeans said it
isn't important who invents something
but rather who does something with it
now we get a somewhat different story
then because the Europeans are inventing
things then we say what's really
important is invention so the transistor
was invented in America but the Japanese
how they did things with the transistor
likely invented consumer electronics but
you know we could have done that but you
know we're too high-minded for that you
know so the question of whether it is
invention or utilization is going to
become anything increasingly a topic in
science and technology as a theme and in
history my favorite one here is that the
lithograph was invented in Europe but
the lithographed book was a standard and
the Muslim world and in East Asia and
the Europeans never developed the
lithographed book but I won't go into
that at the moment onto a a related
topic here a lot of economic history for
the last two or three hundred years has
focused on on capitalism and on capital
why does capital capital accumulate what
is capital used for and so the story of
capitalism starting perhaps with the
great joint-stock companies of the early
17th century has been if you accumulate
the money and if you
invest in producing goods or improving
the production of goods then you get
more money so for them so on and this is
what drives or drove European success so
you look at where did the money to build
railroads of the United States come come
from it was European investors where did
the money for the Suez Canal come from
where the Panama Canal it came from from
euro-american and investors you know who
paid for the undersea cables and so
forth and you see here's the throw of
capital we have the history of banking
so forth and so on so what do we do when
when the biggest reserves of capital
move outside of Europe and America do we
still say that capital is what we should
be following in other words when you're
dealing with with the accumulation of
capital in oil States through the rents
that are collected on the sale of
petroleum products or the capital that
accumulates in China because of trade
surpluses if that capital is used to
develop something is that the same thing
as as the capitalism of the Dutch East
India Company or the English East India
Company do we do we Revere the
capitalist achievements of non European
capitalists right now when you go to
different parts of the world you'll find
that there are enormous projects
underway that are being paid for by oil
capital or even more by Chinese capital
you're saying ok here's a country that
is developed you know its copper mines
being developed by the Chinese or its
pipelines are being built by by the
Chinese and so forth do we fold that
into the history of capitalism even
though it doesn't follow the
institutional structure of of joint
stock companies or do we say that it is
something else and something that is
somewhat unsavory no is a is an Arab
investor or a Chinese investor as good
as a European investor of course none of
them look awfully good right now but
nevertheless thought that the point was
there and I think again sort of like
with the Enlightenment story you have a
a big narrative in modern history that
singles out Europe for certain
achievements and certain you know
attitudes that turn out in the long run
not to be distinctly European that they
start there
and what are you doing with that from
the point of view of history do you do
you give special plaudits to the
Europeans for having invented capitalism
or do you say look you know money is
money and where it accumulates if there
are people are the will to do it it can
produce a more money and there's no
particular virtue to the Europeans
except they happen to be a little
earlier than than other people in in
this as in so many other areas I think
what we're seeing in the last 50 years
is a undermining of the of the
assumption of of European exceptionalism
the assumption that what Europeans did
is better and the the corollary
assumption that it's better because
there is a certain mentality that
enlightened Europeans had that other
people don't because they're held back
by their by their non European
traditions so then we get to the
question of how this relates to religion
why is religion reviving
there has been for a long time
an unspoken and then increasingly after
World War two a spoken assumption that
the modern world will inevitably see the
retreat of religion into the realm of
private observation and private belief
and its movement out of the public
sphere this was a basic assumption of
modernization theory that became popular
particularly United States after World
War Two and it was on this basic
assumption that American scholars and
universities like this one entered into
the study of other parts of the world
now we were going to study other parts
of the world to see to observe as in a
laboratory how in what particular ways
they learn to be like us
and that included how would they become
modern democratic free and capitalistic
but also how would they reject their
their religions how would they throw off
the chains of their religion religious
observance these were taken as ground
assumptions for for modernization theory
then as it as time went on it began to
become apparent that what was supposed
to be fading away was in fact regaining
regaining strength
the revival of religion I think will
become not only an increasing topic for
academic concern but a very challenging
topic from the point of view of world
history because when you have a dominant
narrative of world history that says
follow modernity explain where modernity
comes from define modernity you know
identify the parameters that need to be
that need to be tracked as modernity
spreads around the world and as the
world becomes a global entity one of the
parts of this was that the diminishment
of religion would be a given now if
religion revives or rather as religious
religion revives is it an anomaly is it
a glitch is it somehow modern you know
guarantee not working quite right or is
it a backlash an atavistic Luddite sort
of desire to oppose the wave of the
future or or is it something else is
there something that that explains it
if you are immersed in a faith
environment regardless of the faith well
there is Muslim or Christian or Jewish
or Hindu or Buddhist whatever it is if
you're immersed in a faith environment
you'll find very few people who say that
we are opposed to the modern world we
are you know we want things to go back
to the way they were you know X hundred
years ago if you are immersed in the
secular world it appears to use
self-evident that these people are not
part of the modern world and that
they're trying to turn the back turn the
clock back to you know to a previous age
and and if they use the Internet
and you know nuclear weapons and so
forth in order to to move backwards even
though one might argue that these are
part of the modern world
then then you just say well they're
confused they they're they're really
backward but they're they don't
understand backwardness well enough to
realize that they shouldn't be using all
this cool modern stuff we invented and
made available to them so there's a
problem is there a different narrative
that would explain why religion began to
reappear after World War two is there an
alternative narrative now I don't know I
don't have to invent one until next fall
but since many people in the West regard
the period from World War one through
the Cold War as a period of colossal
civilizational failure in the terms of
the scale of the butchery that occurred
the depth of the fear the the likelihood
seemingly of planetary extinction people
who looked at that way really of yeah
but can't really wouldn't have wanted
this and then you think well what is
more important
caught or mutually assured destruction
so you really have the grounding for
saying that that the West destroyed
itself it didn't literally destroy
itself but it had it today it had a
certain momentum it moved in a certain
direction and then it messed up its
situation so badly that it opened the
door for other people to say there are
other there are other avenues and that
what you get now is a the people who are
complaining about the return to religion
could be viewed as the Luddites the
backward people the people who refuse to
accept that the Western moment came it
was spectacular and it went I have no
idea whether you could sell that idea as
historical analysis or not and then
doubtedly there are bells and whistles
you would have to attach to it but the
idea that modernization theory and its
successor globalisation theory are based
on the idea that Western civilization
really got it right and has every
justification for seeing itself as a
future of the planet
you can argue the other direction and
say that that they got it wrong if you
do that then do you open the door to
religion or to something else you know
Chinese state control development for
example non-religious non-capitalist
non-communist whatever it is I don't
know
now finally the Internet has is changing
everything and it is going to change
historical narratives and it's going to
change them in ways that are very very
difficult to predict certainly the the
last week where we have seen the release
of thousands of secret documents through
WikiLeaks imagine that happening monthly
for the next ten years so that there are
no secrets
the creation of a means of having a
culture that does not have gatekeepers
that does not have that's an unmediated
culture in which everybody gets to say
everything all the time to everybody you
can easily see it as being creating the
world's biggest informational garbage
dump in which there is so much you know
so much nightsoil
piling up that that you're just buried
under it or you can say you know we can
divide this nightsoil
in the most extraordinary ways and
derive meaning from it and of course
this is possible no the
it opens the door for a huge increase in
quantification as a technique for
historical study because there is going
to be so much to quantify and because
the scale of the data to be surveyed is
so enormous that old notions of
expertise are going to disappear I sit
around in my office looking at what a
lovely office I have that's really a
terrific office I have about 4,500 books
in it I think in 50 years will there be
any professor that has 4,500 books in an
office because why bother why have all
that stuff that accumulates dust it
makes you sneeze well I have all those
books around and people say well there
be antiquarians we'll have it say well
why would they have it at a certain
point even they won't bother to have it
you know we don't have anyone who who
who still has a collection of cuneiform
tablets left from the Akkadian period
but there must have been originally when
you had the last cuneiform tablet had
been scribed there must have been 400
century or more people say you know I
have these tablets no I can't read them
but I am waiting for someone in
community I bet they have the coolest
stuff on them here's one shaped like a
sheep liver
you know people must have saved it and
saved and saved it and then and then
found that it was worthless and but it
didn't mean that that the books become
irrelevant because the books become
digitized you find that you can search
better you'll be able to search better
online than you could by walking up and
down the stacks of a first-class
academic library maybe but historians
are going to have to I have to
experiment with this and they're going
to have to to deal with it
what I happen to be a someone who really
loves cyberpunk science-fiction and you
know in William Gibson's one of the
short stories about this future world so
forth II you know in the technological
dystopia that's facing us as our
nightsoil CLECs he has a character who's
wandering through a flea market on the
ruins of the Oakland Bay Bridge and he
finds a book for sale and it's the the
Columbia encyclopedia and when we
published the fourth edition of the
Columbia encyclopedia I gave a speech on
that occasion about the future
encyclopedias and I thought well maybe
that's where it Cyclopes will end up in
a flea market someplace of no interest
and then what happens to encyclopedic
knowledge if it's all so readily
available and and I realize that that
probably in the course of all this I'll
become obsolete but fortunately I'm old
enough not to care a whole lot so thank
you very much
you